[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
a and q section we are raring to go
oh are we going jeopardy edition we're
going to start with the answers jeopardy
yep we're going to start with the
answers and then you guys file the
questions as quick as you can
all right all right petunias nice
nice nice yeah i actually don't know
what question that gorilla glue
wonderful um maybe we ought to go back
to the standard form
okay oh but before we do that
now actually before you do that last
week we had a rare
showing from our third our eldest cat
and he is back now so
uh for those of you curious the uh the
darkest member of our carnivorous
household is
is here that's that's tesla yes tesla
named after
the scientist not the vehicle it's not
that we have anything against the
vehicle
but named after the man himself
um after the live stream ended
during our intermission oh so long ago
immediately locate
my shrew skull which is here and really
i'm not sure you'll get very much
out of um seeing it but what you
will get is that we are the kind of
podcast that has a crew skull
when needed for demonstration purposes
what else do you have in there
uh i believe this is a
hippocidarid no one else has a
hypocedarid skull
other podcasts may have a shoe skill but
a hypocenter it's called i don't think
so
take that smarter every day um so
hypocera you've said it and i talked
over you is a
chiropteran yes it's a bat it's a uh a
horseshoe bat and then here we have a
phylostomid another bat yeah another
microbial leaf nose bat these are the
guys that i
studied you can tell from the skull that
the leaf nose is soft tissue not
skeletal
yep absolutely can all right well that
was fun for me anyway
me too moxie apparently had enough in
his life
yeah she's hit the road the other two
the boycats are here though they're
they're
working through their cream all right
okay so we're gonna start with four
questions from episode 59
go to a question from the discord we
take one question from the discord every
week and then move
right into your questions from this last
hour before moving into questions from
the current hour all right all right we
will turn them all into questions for
the current hour
what nevermind i'm just stating the
obvious because it
allowed me to be in on the conversation
i don't think you have any problem with
that just keeping the flow you're the
guy who brought a hipposidered skull to
the podcast
man hell yeah yeah and a fellow stomach
and a
shrew of some latin name that i don't
know yeah i don't know what the family
tastes
that veritasium wow
i don't know why i'm picking fights with
other science podcasts but
it seemed like the thing to do i guess
it did as a lesbian who was never
so this is uh this is the first question
uh and i
promised to get to it last week uh as a
lesbian who has never conformed to sex
stereotypes i am curious
what makes real trans woman is not
something to identify
into live not by lies and that last a
reference to
um both sultanates essay and perhaps
also radrir's book of the same name that
we talked about extensively in episode
50. um
so um
this is this is a conversation for uh
longer than
a q a and um i think we
may go there a little bit in the letter
wiki that abigail schreier and i do
maybe a little bit um but i would say
this that
um sex is based on what type of gamete
you produce
right if it's um small and zippy versus
large and sessile you're male versus
female
what sex you are is determined
in uh mammals by your chromosomes which
then
affect things um beyond your
um your steroid hormones but um the
steroid hormones being sort of primarily
androgens or primarily estrogens and
progesterone
being highly descriptive of what of
whether or not you're going to become
male or female
and so you have you know you have
chromosomal sex
you have anatomical and physiological
sex which is largely described by
endocrinology although it turns out that
the actual chromosomes the actual x and
y at the
23rd location also um
even absent differences in in hormone
levels
um can affect um
sex like how you manifest your primary
and secondary sex characteristics
and then you also have ways that your
sex is revealed
in your in your brain which includes not
just
you know like the white matter and gray
matter but also how it is that you
perceive what sex you are
we are so complicated and there's so
many things going on
that it shouldn't be surprising to us
that under some conditions
one or more of those systems is not
entirely consistent
and so that that is my very short
uh description you know when when one or
more of those systems
is not consistent with all the rest um
you will have someone who uh
looks one way and is in fact one sex but
feels so certain in themselves that they
are the other thing
um that is not um you know that that is
what gender dysphoria is that you
you have a mismatch and generally
you know it's talked about between sort
of your brain sex what what it is that
your brain
is assuring you of as opposed to the
other
demarcations of sex which are of course
the actual biological sex that you are
yep um i would say you know
this gets more difficult to deal with um
the more uh trans is taken to be
um normal i
don't mean there's anything abnormal
about it because i actually don't think
there is i think it's got
his historical roots well it's anything
super rare can be considered abnormal
well i don't want to say that okay so
the problem is
abnormal carries the connotation of
dysfunction and i
i think there is real trans in the sense
that we see it reflected
in many cultures it's built in it's
ancient
which doesn't rule out the possibility
of arriving there through dysfunction in
modern times be it you know hormones in
the environment you know
or hormone mimics or whatever um however
my point is just simply there is
uh i don't think being trans is easy
and that is to say that at the point
that the discomfort of um
living within the sex to which you were
born is so great that you are
ready to confront the complexity
difficulty
um of transition then the point is
you're actually saying something about
the degree to which things feel off and
that
you'd actually you know prefer to
confront that
process of transition than to remain
where you were
so to the extent that we are going to
valorize transition and encourage people
to think
that any sense that they have that
things that are off or definitely an
indication that you're trans
then this loses all meaning but um
and in fact that's that's really the key
thing that i want to say
is that you know we all all of us
who have grown up in modern times have
dealt
with the confusion of living in a world
that is not
well suited to us right it isn't and so
the number of people
who are going to have the sense
something is definitely profoundly off
and i need a solution that number of
people is going to be
high and therefore the number of people
who will say i know what it is
i don't much like these sex roles that
are inflicted on me i had no choice
about them and you know what
i actually think i prefer that other
thing a number of people who will think
that that's a solution until they've
actually attempted it and discovered
actually you know what
things are just generally off because
the world is not well structured for
people
yeah no it's it's a it's a perfect storm
where all the lunacy of postmodernity
meets all of the market force
and ability to do and both of these
things really do great damage
of big pharma and you just get these two
things together
in this perfect storm in in in trans and
you know i often would say
you know it's trans rights activists as
opposed to
truly trans people truly trans people
being a much tinier
much tinier population with presumably
some slight overlap
between those and you know sort of
everyone else who's
who's doing some combination of activism
and cosplay
and larping and benefiting from
pharmaceutical intervention the likes of
you know the
we do know many of the downstream
effects of a lot of the pharmaceuticals
um both the hormone blockers and puberty
blockers and the actual cross-sex
hormones that are being used
and we don't know most of them i
guarantee you um but the combination of
reality is what i say it is and i will
i'm going to use the market-driven
product over here about which we know
nothing
and uh the makers of which will not
protect me in any way
once the downstream effects are
discovered um comes together just
perfectly in this really
really terrible moment so that is not to
say
again that there isn't some very tiny
number of people who are really
legitimately trans and who are better
off who live
more complete lives most of which don't
have anything to do with their transness
from being able to transition and i
think
maybe to say this in a way that's
clearer than i've ever
said it before hopefully um there is
something
about the desire to avail oneself
of scientific help
in transitioning while denying the
implications of scientific study with
respect to things like sex and gender
one ought to be obligated to one side of
this either you're post-modern and you
really think
the science stuff is just a posture that
people strike in which case
you're wrong but you're entitled to be
wrong in that way um
or you believe in science and you both
want its help but then are
in some sense obligated to the method
for figuring out what's true and what
isn't
and um it is i think driving
many of us crazy to watch a desire for
science a la carte right i want
the drugs i want uh the surgery
i do not want to have to listen to
another word about
the difference between the sexes or the
binariness of sex or gametes or any of
those things
down with trade-offs
[Laughter]
yeah down that the utopians who aren't
up for the fact of tradeoffs are are a
real problem and uh not listening to
them would be a very good idea but all
you have to do is sit down with
trade-offs and
they're done i guess so yeah yeah nice
question
i remember in a past episode some months
ago you guys question some of the
typical procedures done directly after a
baby is born
i'm having a baby soon and wanted to
make sure i do what's best
so i included this um even though i
don't remember
i don't remember our comments on this
front i don't remember if we're talking
about
some of the typical procedures done
directly after a baby is born
um but you know
again a conversation for a longer time
certainly
you know much ink has been spilled over
the medicalizing
of many modern birth procedures
that said as we talked about in the last
hour
we humans are so brainy and our babies
still
so unformed at the point that they're
born the childbirth
really is actually quite dangerous and
so
you know no you should not have you
should not opt for c-section because you
kind of find the idea of vaginal
delivery icky or something that's
actually you're likely to um
to relegate your child to a lifetime of
for instance reduced immune function
as as a result or at least early early
infancy of reduced immune function and
things like using forceps to pull the
baby out of the birth canal you know not
not a good move um typical procedure is
done directly after a baby is born i
don't know there's measurement and stuff
which seems
okay you know basically baby and mom
should be right next to each other right
away yeah that's that's that's the big
thing
um but i feel like even even most modern
hospitals
no longer sort of separate baby and mom
and and don't let them near each other
in part because they were sick and tired
of being blamed for misplacing babies
and
swapping them out with other ones maybe
it solved that problem
um yes if that's not your baby it's on
you it's kind of their
new approach i think because you had it
the whole time
so you're not talking about the baby
literally being on a person i am talking
about
i remember this actually from uh from
when zack was born
the baby is never out of your sight and
so the chances
if the baby has been swapped it wasn't
the hospital i think is their point
swapped in utero
if it was swapped it was you and some
other mother in the hallway
and that's not on them yeah um yeah i
would say i'm very
uh i'm troubled by um
incendiary gender reveal parties
in the flammable west that happens
before the baby is born
it does uh after the baby is bored you
don't need a gender reveal party
with like you're giving it to your
friends
that's not what these things are okay i
am so out of touch
that i apparently misunderstand these
social oh it's like you get i mean we
so we we didn't want to know the sex of
our babies before they were born
um but most people who have the kinds of
prenatal testing that that we had
um end up with which shows whether or
not at that 23rd position you've got an
xx or an xy
and um the gender reveal parties i
understand happen
shortly after those results come in
you're like look it's a
it's a boy it's a girl it's going to be
a boy it's going to be a girl i'm going
gonna light up some fireworks and set
fire to the neighbor's house
right okay well yeah i i'm not anything
else
i mean so you came up with nothing so
far nothing yeah
not nothing but nothing useful um
nothing responsive to the actual
question yeah that
not to put too fine a point on it um
i guess um i'd be interested in a
follow-up if there are any if if you
have you know if there's five
things that are being done that um i'm
not thinking of that we're not thinking
of or that maybe didn't even happen 14
and 16 years ago
um with regard to typical procedures and
yeah you know i'm
i'll bet i and we have pretty
immediately formed opinions based on
what we understand about
um childbirth and deep history yep
i would say um delaying
procedures and something you say
directly after the baby is born which
makes me worried that we're just missing
the category but um
delaying procedures for which there's no
early benefit for as long as possible
right in other words uh if your kid's
gonna get a vaccine
and the reason they're getting the
vaccine is because ultimately they're
gonna end up
in daycare well wait as long as possible
as long as possible
yep but better if again vaginal birth
and breastfeeding
um are providing the kids um
uh immunity for a good long time and you
know if you can't do one or both of
those
then you're in a different position but
yep but i think you know
the general guide and you know there's a
lot of this of course in our book
but uh the general guide is
don't disrupt the normal and intuitive
yeah the baby is built to be raised
you're built to raise it
and um you know uh
there are reasons to change things
right like uh breast pumping obviously
allows a woman to integrate uh the
feeding of her child with her own breast
milk into a world that isn't
particularly well built for it
but it has risks associated with it that
are
subtle yeah actually so we mentioned
this
um in the book our student josie jarvis
um i think generated a hypothesis that
now
actually i think has some possibly some
support in the literature although i'm
not positive with that last part
um which was that um breast milk
uh may also have basically circadian
cues temporal cues and so help entrain
a baby's awake sleep pattern such that
uh what that means is that if if you do
um if you are breastfeeding and you do
pump such that the child is sometimes
getting your milk but not directly from
your breast
that you should basically not just um
you know take care to make it
sterile and freeze it promptly in all of
this but actually time stamp it
and and give your child breast milk that
was pumped at the same time as you're
now feeding it to them
else you're likely to uh make them even
more
chaotically sleepy and waking at times
that are
not going to be particularly pleasing to
you and what fraction
of the dysfunction around childhood
sleep is going to turn out to be
the result that either you broke this
bond entirely by
using formula or you broke it you
introduce
noise by taking breast milk randomly
with respect to time of day
a huge amount and then all sorts of
things may be downstream of that
mental health issues etc so anyway
very easy to disrupt a well-architected
system in which nothing is labeled as to
what it's actually doing and you think
you know milk is food no
milk is a lot of things food is one of
them yeah but it's also informational
well and we do that
i mean food is nutrition no food is also
community building and bonding you know
sex is reproduction no
sex is also relationship building and
bonding you know in humans we turn these
things that had these very
you know in in in older
organisms were pretty simple you know
food was just about nutrition and
keeping yourself warm and
and metabolism and all and sex was just
about reproduction
um but in humans and you know in our
closest relatives and in some other
organisms as well
these things have become imbued with
much more meaning and that's not fake
and it's not a social construct it's
just
it's true yep
next question can you talk about getting
the vaccine now
while pregnant who says i'm pregnant
if i mean talk to you about this um
yeah so this is a tough one you're
dealing with
there's no tests right i mean we have no
idea like no
there's been no safety testing on
pregnant women pregnant women
also there's been very little uh i'm
sure there's some
but there's been very little evidence of
what the effect
on uh on babies
of their mothers having gotten covered
while pregnant
i just saw so you're right and i just
saw and i don't have it to pull up
um that uh apparently immunity
that um woman has from having had kovid
does seem to be passed on to the baby
through breast milk
so that's definitely through breast milk
uh i died
i that was that was what i saw but i
i i don't want to vouch for how good
that that research was
yep um so i guess what i would say
is i think you are
liable to face a medical establishment
which will
underrate the danger not to say that
there is any harm as we've
talked about there's a distinction there
is a danger
in playing russian roulette there's not
necessarily a harm
if you get one of the empty chambers um
so there is a danger in what we don't
know
and that danger is higher than you will
be told because the system
when it says that something is safe is
really telling you
over very short time scales it's safe
and you have to compare that
to the danger on the other side which is
this is a very
serious disease it does long-term damage
it would appear
and
how you compare those things i don't
know but i would say
to the extent that what you really have
is something else you can borrow from
which is if you can stand
to isolate yourself more fully than
others
and protect yourself that way and delay
the vaccine until we know more
about it that's probably what i would do
yeah uh and you know as
as with every question about whether or
not you can do a thing while pregnant
uh it you're going to you know the
earlier in your pregnancy you are
the longer you would have to wait before
getting vaccinated if you decided not to
do it while pregnant
but the more fragile uh that
embryo is and the more likely that um
that something bad could happen with the
pregnancy as a result
of a foreign agent being introduced the
later in pregnancy
you are the shorter you would have to
delay it
um in order to not take it while
pregnant on the other hand
that kid is less and less fragile every
passing day um so you know those
those concerns run in opposite
directions and you just
it's it's not pregnant or not actually
even though
you know that's an old joke from i don't
know the 50s or 60s i'm a little bit
pregnant
well no you're either pregnant or you're
not but how it is that you behave as a
result
is wildly different when you're seven
weeks pregnant versus seven months
pregnant
yeah final question from la
from episode 59 suppose i had an idea
that could possibly address the fourth
frontier problem
i want to explore this idea but i'm
limited by the technology of my wallet
and the disinterest of my friends and
family what should i do
um you gotta figure out how to present
this to your friends and family
in a more compelling way i mean pretty
clearly
so that's where you that's you got to be
able to pitch it first to at least a few
people close to you
or else you have no idea i would say i
mean there's something in the question
the disinterest of your friends and
family my sense if we're talking about
the same thing
um this is super consequential
and pretty interesting and anyway yeah i
think figuring out how to pitch it to
them is a good
uh is a good plan um in terms of
exploring it
geez
yeah i don't know i mean you know but i
think that's a great first step
and you know given given what the nature
of the fourth frontier is which is to
say you don't you don't have a
blueprint in advance but you got to find
the slope but in terms of
you know getting people to poke at it
and see if it makes sense
and you know once you have a few people
who
have hopefully said yeah actually this
but not this here here we go
then using you know using their help to
help spread it
um you know by no means any guarantee at
all
but it has a much greater chance both of
success and that it itself
is a solid idea than if you try to work
entirely alone
yeah that's the thing is you need you
need people who will uh push back and
cause you to find out what you don't
know about your own idea
that's right okay this from the discord
server
uh this addressed to me in particular
there's this vague
mystical and usually negative aura
attached to pms
men are at a disadvantage because they
we can't really grasp what it feels like
and how much it might change one's
behavior
is there a good analog to help men
understand this better
thanks this is a strange one um
rather than speak specifically to pms
which um
you know different women experience so
someone experienced you know
incredibly um huge mood swings
and and actual physiological changes as
well and i i was
i'm lucky not to not to be
such a person so i'd rather than speak
to pms pmss if i
um understand that explicitly there is a
cyclicity
to female hormones um that
men don't have right and and actually
and
boy getting back to the trans thing this
is something
that i don't think
if it's just straight up patches that
are being used
you're never going to get cyclicity if
you are
a male to female trans person you're
just going to have some
stable amount that's always there
and that is very much different from
living in the body of a you know
anything from
you know a 13 to 50 year old woman you
know during
during the reproductive years that
they're that this
i mean i think this this is really one
of the big differences between
between being male and female is um
you know part of why you guys make good
you know
long-distance hunters and such is like
at any moment okay we're doing it like
oh well i was
oh never mind i'm ready like i'll just
go do the thing right and it's not that
there aren't
reasons that you wouldn't be in your
best shape and all of this but
there are many interlocking
and counter dependent or
interdependent rather hormonal cycles
that are known
and therefore presumably many still that
aren't known
that describe women's cycles that
absolutely have effect on
anatomy physiology and mood and so you
know rather than focusing specifically
on pms just
like actually at different points in a
woman's cycle
um there are likely to be different
amounts of creativity
of being quick to anger
of being you know interested in sex and
being
interested in nesting i don't love that
word but
um you know all of these things are
actually basically certain to be true
and some people will reveal
the simplicity less than others but um
this
that cyclicity in hormone
um it's not real you know i they're they
may i don't think this is true
um across like seasons for humans
like like with the migrating songbirds
who
should regrow a pair upon landing um
but because we have moved into an
entirely a seasonal reproductive pattern
um i don't think that there are there's
much in the way of predictable
um cycling hormone levels for men
and therefore i'm not if that's true i
think the answer is kind of like
no like what would be the analog for
some regularly
cycling thing that you can't consciously
get at but there is something that's
changing over time
mark madness oh boy
yeah okay do you even know what sport
that is of course i know what sport that
is it's basketball
okay jeez that was emasculated i was
just gonna say he's gonna say this is
emasculating even though
off airs feel like yeah i know it's
basketball but you know barely because i
never watched it i mean
i feel like i slam dunked that but it's
not bad
um yeah so here's the thing if we take
this simplicity
out of the question right is there an
analyzer there's something to seasonal
sports stuff
actually but sorry go on yeah but it's
not endogenous though
let's put it this way uh fight-or-flight
stuff
um would give a guy a sense of like oh
yeah that was some other part of my
brain that probably
yeah but that's such a rapid ramp right
right it's so such a rapid on-ramp so
it's just
somewhere yeah in the neighborhood
um there's also
[Music]
post-orgasm clarity which is
a widely discussed phenomenon
but anyway the point is okay so shorter
shorter time scale but
yeah again yeah the idea is if
the parts of your brain in these two
conditions if your brain does not look
familiar to itself
across some boundary like somebody said
something to you in a bar and you're
ready to
break a chair over their head yeah or
you've ever been in love in that first
week or two and then six months later
and you're still in love but it's
different right right the the early love
cocktail which is more about
lust and yeah i don't even know what
trick of the mind
yeah yeah um and then
i'm trying to think there's an arctic
monkey's
lyric that i'm searching i thought we
were going to be actually talking about
macaques now
no no no they're not in the arctic no
they're not japanese they're not yeah
those are
distinctly temperate what is the
arctic monkey's lyric there's an arctic
monkey's lyric but i can't quite
i will remember it at some moment when
it's no longer relevant
but um anyway there's a um
oh has something to do uh
with you couldn't behave that way on a
sunday
all right that it just wouldn't it
wouldn't make sense to behave that way
on a sunday
well i mean so that's that's i don't
know i don't know the line
but um you know we obviously impose
cyclicity
right in modernity yeah and the
stereotype is that women are sort of
better at grocking what part of the week
you're in
and whether or not it's a monday and
therefore you have to do x
and it it might actually be related
to um to the fact that women live these
cyclic lives for
you know all of our reproductive lives
without again
mostly being conscious of it at all you
know
it's been it's brought to consciousness
on you know on certain occasions but
um it's mostly just this background like
yeah things are ebbing and flowing
and um and you kind of keep track if you
know
things like you don't want to get
pregnant yeah right yeah i think that's
the thing is that
men have many analogs of one version or
another
few of them are cyclical um and
persistent right
right yeah um actually the one that i
think
might be the strongest one i ever
encountered
was i'm speaking literally here
profound thirst like when you really
[ __ ] up and you didn't bring enough
water on some
very long hike that
thing alters who you are so quickly and
profoundly
um that anyway i just think
if you can tap into something like that
and just recognize
like wow i was so thirsty i wasn't
myself right
yeah that that uh that begins to
get at the much more subtle but regular
cyclicity and yeah because it's because
the hormonal changes
in in women's reproductive cycles
are are cyclic uh
you know all of that is you know myself
herself
whatever right like there is no like i
wasn't myself like i was my best self
maybe yeah like that's not the self i i
i wish i was always this self over here
and then sometimes i'm the self we all
have that but
um but it's probably more reliably like
okay at you know day 18 or what i don't
know what but
you know at days 2 and 18 are going to
be around when i'm not at my best self
yeah i just totally made up those
numbers but right
one final thing i will say is that i did
generate a hypothesis one of my
favorites actually
4 pms and
i taught it it was the one place where i
got into trouble with
classes right there was something
not everybody but a small number of
people almost reliably whenever i taught
this to a class
um rebelled not that there was anything
wrong with my idea or that it didn't
make sense but they because it was you
yeah they because you tested the idea
uh even having a hypothesis about this
so are you gonna share it or are you
gonna save it uh i'm definitely saving
this one in fact it's uh it's one i'm
looking forward to
deploying with the right evidence and a
proper context
but yes i do believe it it needs an
explanation
and um that there is one all right
okay let's actually get to today's
question shall we sure
right so um given enough time in tech
wouldn't transsexualism trans racialism
and trans speciesism
become a virtual certainty and even the
norm like how dyed hair is today
seems like an engineering problem
masking is a social problem with people
pushing acceptance before we even have
the solution
whereas if it could be done as safely
easily cheaply and reversibly as
changing clothes
no one would care about it and the abuse
would go away
so the pro i want to leave
transracialism out of it
um but transsexualism and trans
speciesism
are a denial of a true
thing that has a deeper history with
more complexity in it
than anyone can possibly understand
and while it is true that if you dye
your hair you're probably toxifying
yourself and
having effects at one level you've just
changed the color of your hair
and that's it and it is a simple
parameter there's a simple switch
and maybe it's not a toggle but it's got
you know a few possible states and you
can choose
you know any of one through six and sort
of done
there may be downstream effects but um
depending on what dye you use there
certainly
will be um but they're they're minor
all things considered there is
no such thing there is no dye there is
no hair dye analog for changing your sex
uh although some would argue that that's
the cross-sex hormones
nope that's not sufficient and there
certainly is no equivalent for changing
your species
just not a thing just just not not not
possible
so this this presumes that these
are social problems um i think actually
um and also misunderstands biology for
engineering
like we're not machines we're we're
complex evolved things
that can't be manipulated by you know
pulling a few levers
yeah uh i will just add that uh
years ago aubry de gray
i'm sure he still does um aubry de gray
who is
my antithesis in the world of senescence
research uh argued that curing
senescence that is
growing feeble with age that that was
simply an engineering problem
and that therefore if we get to it we'll
beat it
and my point in response uh in a long
forgotten
uh challenge over this was just because
it's an engineering problem doesn't mean
it's a tractable engineering problem
right and so i used the example of
converting a you know 1967
ford mustang into an operable
uh you know rocket that you could launch
to the moon and return to the earth
is an engineering problem but it doesn't
you know without ever taking it offline
right um it doesn't make it tractable
and so species transition yes is it is
it an
engineering problem that you know that
you would have to change one creature
into another creature
at an atomic level you know i guess
but um no i mean you can't even because
you know it requires time travel
well you know species is about lineage
and if you did right
you know it's about lineage but the fact
is you know a squid
has a organization of atoms and you
could take the atoms from one creature
and
reorganize them into the other creature
but the point is you wouldn't get any of
the things that you would hope to get
out of that it's not like
this creature that you disassembled
would have the experience of that
creature
so you know squid of thebes it is the
squid
it is the squid of thebes yes a
reference that will
land with no one with almost no one yes
arnold if you're out there
it's the squid of thieves
with that let's go on to the next
question um just a comment here your
interference during the fires was likely
static
due to a huge drop in humidity lovely
except we falsified that hypothesis
and the way we did that i thought you
had was we humidified the hell out of
the room with a steamer that we
left left running and we kept putting
more water in it and so we drove the
humidity up well above what it would
have been under normal circumstances
that's what that was doing up here
for so long oh yeah i thought you were
just covertly steaming a lot of clothes
it does sound like me but no in this
case i was i was hypothesis
testing that it was the humidity because
we actually thought that was the most
likely explanation except
it had no effect so yeah um good thought
but nope yeah uh brett if you are right
about asymptomatic people not being
contagious do you think the infections
are because too many decide not to
isolate
i think asymptomatic spread is more
likely to be the main cause
why can't we have data on asymptomatic
viral load
so there is i just saw an acquaintance
just sent me a paper that i i'm not
gonna be able to find right now
finding basically no evidence of
asymptomatic spread
in china in the early days in wuhan and
surrounding areas
where they had gone they had done
extreme lockdown for a couple of months
and then this is like
the population i'm remembering uh
uncarefully maybe here but like a
population of like 10 million people
for a span of 19 days they tried to get
as many people
tested it wasn't a pcr test i don't
think anyway tested
um to see if they were positive or not
and they got like 92 percent
of this 10 million person population and
they found
and um and you know some 30 000 of them
or so had
tested positive recovered before um
of all these people there was there were
none who were showing symptoms after
this extreme lockdown early right
and then 300 people or so show up as
being asymptomatic but having coveted
and they find zero evidence for any
asymptomatic transfer
now this runs counter to the example i
gave here i think
last week of a woman i know who
experienced asymptomatic transfer in her
place of business
yep um but but that
that really big study is pretty powerful
and i'll
try to pull it up hopefully for another
time yeah a couple things that uh belong
in the mix on this question one uh a
angela rasmussen point uh
which is that we mustn't mistake
asymptomatic for pre-symptomatic
um so that's important if you're going
to develop symptoms we need to classify
you differently because there will be a
point at which
they're too subtle to trigger conscious
awareness but
you're headed there two
it is impossible that there's no
asymptomatic transmission
at all because you will have people who
are in denial about their symptoms and
their symptoms you know some people will
have a set of symptoms that can't be
diagnosed from the outside
and so if you are in denial i really
don't want to have had covid
because of the stigma or whatever or i
don't have to quarantine of course i can
taste that
right right um so you'll get a certain
amount that way
which is you know not really
asymptomatic
right so that's not about the disease
actually being transmissible
yeah when you're asymptomatic that's
about the social overlay of how people
behave
exactly um and the last thing
uh is so first of all the reason that we
expect
asymptomatic transmission to be very low
is that what symptoms
are is the result of damage
that happens to tissues in the process
of creating more virus so
for example you and i have talked about
the fact that sometimes if we you know
end up giving each other a cold or
something like that
um that we will get the disease
differently right you have
particular symptoms and i tend to have
other symptoms i tend to get in the
lungs you tend to get it in the throat
that's right um and that this you know
there
can be lots of reasons for that but the
basic point is your symptoms are a
measure of
where the lesions have happened that are
putting out virus and um so in any case
you can have them in places where you're
less innervated and so the symptoms are
much more subtle but in general
all else being equal we'd expect
proportionality
between your level of symptoms and your
level of transmission because
the point is it's a measure of how much
tissue is involved in producing
viral particles so
anyway uh all that is to say
you're not going to get a perfect uh
black and white description
of of how this
works but you will get a strong
correlation and it does appear from that
study
that uh asymptomatic transmission is at
least pretty rare
yeah next question crisper editing of
sperm to create gene-edited babies
is this possible and is it a moral
loophole to the editing of a fertilized
egg
i don't know what that last part means
exactly the distinction morally speaking
between editing the sperm and editing
the egg
yeah um and
you know is it possible i don't think
it's possible yet but i think it's going
to be possible
well there's a question of technically
possible and
usefully possible right
so for example
we do know enough
to i don't want to say we know enough
because it's possible that there's a
link in that chain we don't know
but the thing that i always say about
crispr is that we
have a typewriter now for genes we can
type
any gene we want right de novo
but we don't have the rosetta stone we
don't speak gene so there's a question
about how
okay congratulations we're giving you
this crispr device and a tech team
and you're going to be able to edit your
baby and it's it's a bit like somebody
saying
um you know
you have uh this um you know
here is a typewriter that uh types in
russian
and uh you know we would like you to uh
edit
shakespeare we want you to be the the
russian shakespeare
and the answer is well that's not
sufficient yes in theory there's nothing
you couldn't type on a russian
typewriter including things the
equivalent of
what shakespeare wrote but a in terms of
editing
a baby's genome you are up against
natural selection which has done an
amazing job and
you know the selection process has
edited down to the
best of everything right with very few
exceptions
um and so the chances that you're going
to beat that because you know better
right is pretty damn low um but we just
simply don't have the rosetta stone yet
which doesn't mean it isn't coming
right and this goes back to the
discussion we had about
the prediction of the protein folding
that there may be
a simpler rubric than we know but we
ain't there
with respect to we don't speak gene yep
yep
please help settle an argument is the
thumb a finger my girlfriend insists
that the thumb is not a finger and i
insist that it is a finger we just call
it a thumb
everyone knows we have ten fingers and
ten toes right
yes it's a finger i knew you were going
to say that and i know exactly what
logic it's based on and i agree
but do you want to spell it out further
oh no there's no but i thought you could
also
disagree no no i i i just
i agree that this is a very
straightforward
answer and you believe so well
okay maybe we we should be moving faster
rather than slower but
um to the degree that thumb and finger
are human-made categories
you could argue that a hand is made up
of
a thumb and four fingers to the degree
that these things on our hands that are
digits
are inherited from a most recent common
ancestor
they are all digits they're all made of
phalanges they all have
uh comparable developmental uh
trajectories and genes and coding for
them and yes the thumb
can can do this opposable thing with the
pinky
but that's more about the attachment
point down in the carpals metacarpal
space near the wrist
than about anything different about the
digits so they're all
all digits they're all phalanges just
like the toes are
but the one has a particular
functionality that the others don't on
the other hand
you can do things with all of your
fingers that you probably can't do with
any of them
so this is a nested set issue
right yes fingers and toes are all
digits
and thumb is a subset of
finger which is a subset of digit yeah
that's right
and i mean so and maybe maybe one more
way to go at it
is um maybe only because of the naming
convention because of the categories
that we use and i don't know if this is
the same in every other language out
there but
we don't call our biggest toe not a toe
like no one is under the impression that
there's like
a big toe and then four toes on a foot
it's like you have five toes and then
some people will say well you have a
thumb and four fingers
well that's only because we have lost
the prehensility
is that a word no it is the prehensility
of our big toes chimps have prehensile
big toes and
you know they're they're climbers more
than we are you don't mean prehensile oh
i'm sorry not prehensile opposable sorry
um so i invented a word
for entirely the wrong context i have to
i have to retract that yeah
yeah so um we've lost the the
opposability of our big toes because
we're mostly walking on flat land and it
actually is
uh we have better grip uh when we have
flatter feet without a
opposable big toe and as such because it
looks more like the other digits
we don't give it a special name we just
give it like an adjective description to
go with toe
and we could just as well have done the
same thing with fingers this is just
like it's a linguistic confusion because
of the because of the naming categories
we've given it not
but the actual nested set is a big toe
is a toe
the thumb is a finger and they're all
digits
yep i i think that's right and uh the
number of
puns that you could wield mercilessly
in this challenge to your girlfriend is
many and i suggest that you show
no mercy because you are in fact correct
that the thumb is a finger
no mercy none oh well okay
i'm supposed to start a master's degree
in the united kingdom starting in
january 2021.
i'm canadian does the mutant virus pose
enough threat that i should consider
abandoning my scholarship
on happy face ps best show ever
thank you oh boy um
i don't know what to think about this
mutant
i don't either um i was having a
discussion with the uh
the group this morning on the uh patreon
call about this
and it is bewildering to me that we are
being fed
a nonsense story we are clearly being
fed another
right okay there's a new the virus has
mutated
yes every hour of every day it's
mutating many many places this is a
mutant with you so far
okay good so now you've got a mutant
that has
changed enough and spread widely enough
that we
can recognize it as its own unique
phenomenon good
perfect um should we be concerned yes
it's much more transmissible
okay 70 more transmissible did it borrow
from somewhere
in order to get there was there an
inefficiency in the original in which
case
why is it that with many hundreds of
trillions of copies of this thing out
there it hadn't discovered that
earlier on and many times over therefore
probably not that
therefore probably it barred from
somewhere probably therefore where to
borrow from is it less awful in some
other way
right or did it borrow from
the lack of it
imagine this we adapt to this thing over
time our viewers will have registered
that we were very concerned about fomite
transmission at first and we got over
that because it doesn't seem to be
transmitted
very frequently that way that means
you've got a lot of people out there who
aren't paying that much attention to
surfaces right wouldn't that be a great
way to increase your transmissibility is
to go
some route and that's readily plausible
so did it borrow from somewhere
and then the one that i really don't get
is
this variant it's apparently four months
old it's been recognized
for four months that means this isn't
the uk
there's no conceivable way given the uk
was not quarantined in the uk was less
quarantined than other countries because
it allowed people to travel
why are we not talking about how this
variant is doing
on presumably it is on every continent
other than antarctica yeah
whereas usually this question is insipid
and meaningless
why now like why are we hearing about
this now why is why
is this showing up as a thing right now
if it has been described for four months
right
and i'm not saying it isn't a thing i'm
not saying it isn't 70
more transmissible but i'm saying the
immediate questions that should be
generated upon
that discovery does not seem to be
discussed anywhere
well that i've seen yet and that has me
wondering
what the heck is up so are you prepared
to give
advice on this one well i don't i don't
think i can
all i can say is this i think we in
general
most people underrate the danger of
covid because the case fatality rate
is low death is not the thing to fear
but damage is the thing to fear
i think the idea that this is a uk
phenomenon after four months of
circulating with a very high
transmissibility i mean covet is already
highly transmissible
to be you know substantially more
transmissible
means it has escaped which i think means
one of several things will be true
it will either do the same thing in the
rest of the
world that it has done in the uk or
there's something about the story that
doesn't make any sense so
my guess is you can't really protect
yourself from this variant by avoiding
the uk that that's
almost entirely going to be an artifact
of the journalism here
and not the virology or the epidemiology
so you probably can't protect yourself
from it that way should you be worried
about a much more highly transmissible
sars kov2 yeah i would be
curious about your thoughts on bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies more generally
um i am 45 seconds i'm a fan
of the idea i think a tremendous number
of things are possible in the space
the solution to many of our problems i
am watching
a awareness of the
liberty liberating potential of these
things dawn
on entities that would rather we not be
liberated and so there's a question
about whether or not
crypto will endure the attempt to uh
bring it into the larger finance
structure and set of laws but i'm
hopeful there's lots of stuff including
um
preventing voting anomalies and fraud um
freeing the internet from the censorious
instinct of numbskulls
with tech platforms all sorts of stuff
is possible there so i'm hopeful
but uh we need to
you know deal with the many demons that
haunt the landscape between here and
there
yep all right uh next question
are you familiar with arthur c clarke's
three laws when i hear you say things
like tech can't save us or will never
find a cure for cancer senescence it
reminds me of the first law
since won't recursive ai change that so
i just
remember i just looked it up yes the
first one any sufficiently
sophisticated technology is
indistinguishable from magic now
that's the third one oh the so-called
laws are
this is just wikipedia when a
distinguished but elderly scientist
states that something is possible he is
almost certainly right
when he states that something is
impossible he is very probably wrong
two the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture a
little way past them into the impossible
and three any sufficiently advanced
technology is instinctual
from magic so i will say i
had not run into these before that i
sense of clark is that he was
amazing but that he had the same problem
that almost
all brilliant science fiction has and
pretty much all bad science fiction does
which is that he really really well
understood physics
and other engineering like some systems
and really didn't get the biology and he
did better than many
um but you know this is this is the
point that i've made about the sci-fi
that i have written is that you know my
my goal is to yes get the physics right
and that's not easy but to also get the
biology right because no one
seems to be doing that and i feel like
clark's law here
is specifically imagining that complex
biological systems are engineering
systems and all you have to do
is figure out why they're tractable and
you know to your point about
the typewriter uh with russian i mean i
feel like we've we've done this
and you know clark just isn't going to
end up being right um that every
every problem is ultimately tractable
yeah there's there's a tractability
issue but i also think
um you know i get the question and i i
appreciate it
um but you have to understand what it
means to say
that it's not possible um my claim would
be the senescence problem is solved
100 and that the solution is about as
perfect as you could hope for you just
don't like it and that's the problem it
doesn't look like an
answer to people right it looks like the
problem and the
you know the answer the solution is to
not solve the breakdown of the body
as the result of the loss of information
about the position of
cells and things like that but to renew
the process by creating children and
loading only that fraction of the
software that makes sense into them so
they are not burdened with the legacy
code
yada yada yada it's an incredibly
elegant solution
right but when people say they want to
cure senescence what they're really
saying is
i want a cure that preserves me
right yeah that's what they want and the
answer is well that doesn't even
really make sense you're trying to solve
a problem that isn't even coherent
right do you really would you like to
save you
for the world of 5000 years from now
because my guess is you're gonna be an
old foggy like nobody's business five
thousand years from now even if we did
manage to preserve you
so wouldn't it be better if an updated
version of you existed
so anyway yeah um many things are
possible
they may not be possible in exactly the
way we would like them to be possible
but
um that
it doesn't that doesn't render
intractable problems tractable
so um every question that came in this
last hour
is terrific and i really would like to
get through all of them and we won't but
we'll pick up some of them
next time i'm going to get through a few
more but happy
christmas han no happy chris mohanna
kwanzaa
chris muhammad as well yes to you too
have you heard of the great barrington
declaration if so what are your thoughts
on their public policy proposals thanks
for your work this year it has kept me
sane through all the chaos
thank you for that um we've been asked
this a lot and i have gone and dipped
into it a little bit
and just have not i just i
just don't know enough to say yeah i
don't yeah i'm not even sure what it's a
reference to
oh it's uh it's a rejection of
most of the uh societal level response
to covid
um by public health officials i think if
i'm if i'm remembering correctly
there are a number of these there's you
know there's also the great reset thing
um and this is this is sort of the
opposite in some ways
um but we obviously don't know enough to
say
a lot about it right now um
hi both please explain and riff on the
beautiful evolutionary concur
concurrence i think convergence uh of
the hummingbird
and the hummingbird hawk moth both adept
for hovering nectar extraction are there
other examples of close evolutionary
adaptation love you too
yeah perfect um so beautiful
that uh so hawk moths are sphinged moths
are these very high energy highly
agile um moths that are
i think all nectar fueled if i'm right
uh heather's gonna bring up a an image
of one
you know so these sort of fighter jet
looking um
creatures and of course it makes perfect
sense so that's a beautiful one yeah
it makes perfect sense um for their
behavior to be
similar to that of hummingbirds because
of course they're solving a similar
ecological problem
but you set us up perfectly to reveal
the third one
that's right right the third one is that
there are bats that do the very same
thing as hummingbirds
um i call them humming bats i'm not sure
anyone else does but
they should they should and they're
they're very hummingbird-like they
hover in a similar way i once took a
photograph i got one photograph that's
anywhere near decent
who is it what's the that's the genus
esophaga
uh esophagusaurus sorosino am i
remembering that correctly
um
so anyway these are uh bats that uh
pollinate flowers over there so yeah
that's a good picture
that's gonna be merlin tuttle of course
yeah merlin tuttle the great bat
photographer
um who also is the founder of bat
conservation international merlin if
you're out there
good to see ya um it's a very worthy
organization
but in any case these bats uh
that's bananas yeah it sure is it's
going after bananas
yes in fact bananas are often um
protected
from the claw marks that
bats would put in them which are taken
to be off-putting by consumers and so
bap
banana farms often protect their their
fruits from
from roosting marks but anyway the point
is
bats do the same thing and what um
um why am i forgetting marco's last name
so i studied
uh briefly i was helping out a guy um
at la selva who uh became a very
important bat researcher
silva being one of the big neotropical
research stations
in costa rica yeah in sarapaqui region
of costa rica
um marco i'm kicking myself that i've
misplaced his last name for the moment
but anyway marco was studying uh
glossophagine
these hummingbats and he was netting
them to figure out what their behavior
looked like and what he was discovering
was that their behavior looks exactly
like hummingbirds and right down to the
trap lining so
if you think about the um the puzzle
if you're a plant and you're trying to
get a bird or a bat
to take your pollen to other members of
your species because that's
in essence the whole point of the of
putting out a flower
then you don't want to give the creature
so much reward
that it um just hangs out at that flower
and drinks all night because that's
pointless and you don't want to give it
so little reward that it doesn't come to
visit your flower and it goes to some
other flowers so there's this
game theory that plays out between the
flowers and the animals that results in
the animals
trap lining so they make a predictable
because they're very
expensive to run i mean an animal that
is
fluttering like that is spending a lot
of resource
so the animal picks the best path
through some series of plants that it's
visiting whatever plants happen to be
flowering
and basically it gets very good at
running the trap line a trap line being
an analogy to old
you know trappers would put out traps
and they would visit them to see if they
had caught anything
so anyway both hummingbirds and
hummingbats
and i believe sphingid moths do this
trap lining thing because it's the most
sensible way to solve the problem
of being pushed to the next flower by a
plant that wants to feed you enough to
get you to come back but not so much
that you stick around
so anyway it's a very nifty set of
systems and yes a whole lot of
convergent evolution
isn't nature wonderful yes it is
i'm not a phd but i've recently carried
out a study on birds that turned up
significant results
should i try to publish an academic
paper also i do research art and blog
sometimes i stim stumble into a
situation where i can actually
contribute to a field of study
thanks for everything that's cool i love
this um
here's what i would do i would say yes
you should try but if they shut you down
which they probably will because that's
what they are i mean they're literally
gatekeepers
yep yeah if they shut you down then take
it public
yeah just reveal what you've discovered
you're you're entitled to do science
and if you've discovered something cool
that's awesome
and uh give us a pointer to it if you
found something cool and you want to
make a little video that explains
your findings and your methods and those
sorts of things we'd love to look at it
and you know they can't stop you from
talking about it in public
yeah and yeah like the the gatekeeping
you without a an institutional
affiliation presumably would not be able
to get grant money on your own
um but those particular
gates do not exist with regard to
publishing it's going to be harder to
get taken seriously you may just get
rejections uh without ever knowing why
because the editor saw that you don't
have those letters after your name and
therefore they don't even
read what you've written but you know
depending you haven't said anything
about what kind of a study it is you
know ecological
behavioral physiological what um
but depending at least you know if it's
over in sort of
organizable biology natural history
space
there are a lot of bird specific
journals that do
that will publish smaller pieces
even if they're big pieces of research
but from people who they might not
necessarily always publish so that's you
know that's a possible way in
possible although there is an awful lot
of gatekeeping even the archive
which shouldn't have any requires an
institutional affiliation to gain access
to it
really yeah do you mean to get put do
you get to to put yourself on it
that was certainly true a few years ago
i don't know that it's still true but i
assume it is
that's really unfortunate okay um
so like i said there's so many good
questions here but we're going to switch
to the next hours question so we can get
through a few of them
keep america weird all caps keep america
western education no educated
industrialized rich and democratic
yeah let's let's hope i think um
i was wondering if you could describe
the importance of evolutionary medicine
and where to learn about it to someone
who will start med school next year
oh goodness well we hope we're not
messing you up
the key to integrating evolutionary
medicine into your study of
medicine in medical school will be
keeping your mouth shut when
necessary um you're looking at me that
way
it's just not helpful advice right here
i believe it to be literal advice that i
don't want to have to give but
the problem is because medicine and
psychology and ophthalmology and
dentistry are all taught as if
we didn't know anything about darwinism
there is resistance to this and so
evolutionary medicine to the extent it
exists is not a
medical program it's outside it's an
evolutionary program
true but that's a political response
rather than a how do i learn about it
right like where
where can this person learn say two
things
um george williams and randy nessie
wrote an excellent book which is
basically the founding text
of this discipline it's called why we
get sick
um it's still the classic even though
it's now
30 years old a little less than 30 years
old published in the early 90s
um incidentally on the back cover i
think it has a blurb from richard
dawkins who says
get two copies and give one to your
doctor yeah which i
did and it caused a little bit of
consternation
um so anyway that's the the long and
short of it but
george williams sadly is gone randy
nessie is very much
not gone and is now the head of an
important maybe
the important evolutionary medicine
institute and no doubt
if you look up the institute you will
find pointers to the
most important journals blogs etc
uh this book
is also something that i recommend
highly the story of the human body by
daniel lieberman
serve the human body subtitle of which
is evolution health and disease it's
it's more modern so it's a little bit
more up to date with regard to
just a few things that we have learned
um
um since it's not i guess you know it
just it's telling me that i purchased
the item in august of 2014. so
you did it's not brand new um
and then boy there's another's an
article just out
um here i'm going to ask the next
question and
then have you answered while i look for
this article see if i can find it
because someone who's going to med
school should well be able to
understand a primary article on
on let me just find it and uh
and see if it's relevant um next
question why is there more competition
in the tropics
less seasonality reliable resources does
competition also increase between humans
and hot house conditions if so which
wouldn't the above decrease competition
and not from our friend echo
all right so i'll let you go for it
while i try to find this
yeah let's just say um so this was one
of the
primary topics in my my dissertation and
the counterintuitive
thing is that the temperate zones
which are less competitive
are more difficult to evolve
in response to because of their
capriciousness
so that is to say the weather
doesn't care about you right that means
some days it smiles on you and some days
it delivers you
harsh challenges and predicting them is
difficult because it
is not something that has an interest
your competitors have an interest
whether it is getting to
lunch before you do or poisoning you
so that you disappear from the landscape
or whatever but that force that they
apply
is consistent enough that you can adapt
to it and so
in some sense the argument that i
deployed in my dissertation for why
species are more
numerous in the tropics and that is true
at every scale
is that in effect the competitors
drive each other to ever greater
competitive ever greater competitive
efficiency
and that the cost of competitive
efficiency is the narrowness of niche
which means that a species that was
broadly distributed
and had broad tolerances gets narrowly
distributed and divided up
in order to be a more ferocious
competitor so
it is a downstream consequence of
conditions being more consistent over
time
and that leaving competition as the
dominant hostile force rather than a
flip-flop
between competition on the one hand
and climb it on the other awesome
that was a super packed synopsis
it was it was pretty dense very good
very good um
just to go back for a moment to the
person who's entering med school next
year so we have a couple of chapters in
our book which will be out
um middle of next year ish middle to the
end of next year
on medicine and health from evolutionary
perspective
um but there's this article zach you can
show
the co-author is the same daniel
lieberman who wrote the story of the
human body so this is girvin and
lieberman just published this year 2020
called weird bodies mismatched medicine
and missing diversity
so if you've got a higher ed affiliation
you should be able to find this article
it's published in
evolutionary human behavior and it's
also um
a really good introduction to some parts
of
evolutionary medicine yeah maybe also
uh a pointer to paul ewald
um well yeah possible i
i would i don't remember what of of his
though so
i wouldn't know what to what to point to
i i don't offhand either maybe
we'll come back to it but i'm just not i
don't i don't recall well enough to know
for sure if that's
going to be relevant just a quick
question out of the alpine country of
austria
do you know of any higher mutation rates
caused by epigenetic changes
mutation rates caused by epigenetic
changes
um there will certainly be higher
mutation rates
epigenetically influenced based on
things like
[Music]
histone wrapping which will expose
dna to greater or lesser interactions
with
the environment but i'm not quite sure
i'm not sure if alpine is relevant to
the question
yeah and if we're talking about humans
or virus or some other or just across
the board
um i don't know either yeah so
it's certainly plausible but whether
it's relevant to what you're
looking for we don't know yeah i agree
core and solar forcing in quotes core
and solar forcing are taking grip in
climate science
sun influences clouds and core materials
north pole is moving to siberia is this
a coincidence
i don't know what to make of this i
remember something about
solar forcing um
i i don't thought it was involved in the
milankovitch albedo feedbacks
um but i don't remember well certainly
the sun influencing clouds and such
sounds like an albedo
uh reference but uh
and you know north pole moving could
affect milankovitch cycles i i don't i
don't know enough about what's going on
here
north pole moving is a strange
construction
you know as the tilt changes the
magnetic and the true north are going to
be slightly
differently aligned right so you know
we're moving between
we're right in the middle right now so
we've got like a 23.5 degree tilt right
now we move between something like a 22
and a half to a 24.
i did that the wrong way um 22 and a
half to 24.
yeah but it's so tiny it doesn't move
the north pole to siberia um
yeah i don't know i'm trying to imagine
like what
so i'm going to how close to siberia to
the north pole i don't i don't know
i mean it's the arctic ocean yeah so
yeah i think so uh so i'm not sure if
there's something metaphorical in that
claim yeah
uh or not um anyway
yeah i wish i knew because so that's a
very interesting
uh set of feedbacks but indeed
um brett the last
circumcision question seem to be about
choice it can pass the adaptive test but
why make the choice for the baby instead
of
letting them decide when they're older
the son can weigh his pros and cons and
choose
um this is gonna be the thing that just
keeps on coming back i guess it is
yeah i had a friend who was
i think he was re-circumcised for
religious reasons late in life and it
was
very traumatic so in some in some ways
i think uh this is about
um not traumatizing
you know yes it's probably traumatic for
the baby and they're probably over it
a minute or two later um
so anyway i mean i i don't know what to
tell you i i do
i do think people make more of this
issue than than they should
and you know we've given
the part of it that i think we're
especially qualified to talk about which
is
foreskin passes the adaptive test the
removal passes the adaptive test
we can't say very much about the
whys and that does seem to make it
defensible either way
next question what sorts of mutations
would best support differential success
in modern times
for males for females i'd like to better
understand the selection criteria
i think this is too blunt a a
tool yeah the idea here is that
any evolutionary change in humans are
going to be genetic mutations
and of course the the vast majority of
evolutionary change that we're
experiencing now
is not at the genetic level i agree i
think
um you know you're part of the species
that has the greatest
opportunity to be flexible and to
innovate and all of that and it hasn't
you know it was set in motion by genes
that created a brain that was very much
not genetically pre-wired which isn't to
say zero percent
but it's to say less than any other
species and so that's the answer is
you know what makes you uh
better able better prepared is uh
flexibility which you have in spades yep
okay let's just go let's do
four more a couple of which are very
brief because they're just comments um
should humanity commit to slowing the
earth's orbital speed until we achieve a
360-day year
yes absolutely 100 and we should get
right on it
yeah um yeah that would make things
simpler the math would just be so much
easier
yeah so much more elegant i mean we're
so close
we're so close or we could praise god is
definitely punking us
yes he is punking us and we should pray
for him to stop
what it says reasonable approach as any
yeah absolutely very few side effects
what side effects there are might even
be positive
imagine 90 day seasons perfect yeah
obvious
totally yeah thank you for that
[Music]
why not just designate saunas bathrooms
and changing rooms by genitalia
could anyone game that
um i don't want to have to check
yeah i mean that's certainly
my first thought you know sauna isn't
changing yeah yeah whose job is it to
check
um yeah i mean a
tiny tiny tiny number of people who have
ambiguous genitalia who are actually
intersex
yeah but um i mean it's not
operationalizing it would be tough
because he was going to check but it's
it's not terrible here's the thing i
mean in some sense it's it it's a
reinvention of exactly what this person
is suggesting
but this whole idea that this is all
about symmetry it's actually about
asymmetry
right you've got people who are in need
of protection and it occurred to me
after
our stream ended that it's not just that
males are
bigger on average or that pregnancy is a
disproportionate cost for females
but anatomically males are
built in a way that they can force
themselves on females and the reverse is
much much less plausible
right those three things basically
answer the question of
who it is that needs to be protected
how we do that i don't know but at some
level let's not over complicate it
that's the point
and um to the extent that your
newfangled rubric
violates the principle of we should
protect those who are most in need of
being protected
it's a bad it's a a non-starter yeah
from my perspective
uh the penultimate question here is meow
yes definitely yep for sure and finally
can you share your philosophy on when to
listen to experts
how should one navigate disagreements
from experts in the same field or
between different fields
what are common blind spots for experts
oh yeah um um
i would say yeah it's not as simple as
when to listen
you know what there's actually another
expert's question so let me just read
that one okay
as well um so that we can just try to
lump these together
are we living in the age of experts or
in the age of socially driven content
why do you find one or the other more
preferential
i don't think that's a complete solution
set i would hope yeah
i think there's a we've got a an
expertise
problem which is that our experts very
frequently aren't expert
right and so there are many cases you
would want to listen to experts on
coronavirus but our experts suck they're
corrupt
and so because they're corrupt you can't
afford or
or too narrowly trained so they don't
know what they think they know
let's put it this way i think that's a
problem we got narrow training
we've got um you know
biases and the types of error that we
prefer
these biases are themselves corrupt
because we don't want to
disrupt certain kinds of business even
if it causes us to massively disrupt
others
um and in some sense you have to go
with the individual is trustworthy and
one of the things that the individual
being trustworthy is about is do they
tell you what the limits of their
knowledge are or tell you
how they would know if this was wrong
right to the extent that some expert
wants to assure you
of the right answer so you can turn off
your brain they're probably no good
and i'm trying to remember what the
example was
you and i got something oh i got
something wrong
a couple of live streams ago it was
what was it about i had it just a second
ago
it was about oh yeah adaptive immunity
and vertebrates it was about how far
back adaptive immunity
went and the reason i'm highlighting
this is yep
i'm an expert in biology i got this
biological thing wrong
but if you look at the conversation that
surrounded it
i told you where i suspected my logic
was probably
going to upend me and i gave you the
things that pointed in the direction of
the other answer right and the point is
that's what you want is somebody who's
willing to show their work
enough that at the point they do get it
wrong a they'll say so b
you'll see how they got there c you can
figure out what the consequence of the
error will be
in other words that's what show your
work is for yeah show your work is so
that you can evaluate all of those
things and to the extent look you may be
in a different position than i am and it
may be
that although i think this is the right
answer if i show my work then you can
say even if that is probably the right
answer the risk of the other answer is
so substantial
i'm going to hedge against it so anyway
yeah somebody who will show their work
is
yeah that's what you're looking for so
in terms of navigating
disagreements um you know too often you
know especially if it's talking heads
it's mainstream media and you get you
know 30 seconds to three minutes
the most to explain a point there's no
there's no tolerance built in for any
kind of explanation nuance hedging any
of it you know hedging
in this case i mean entirely positively
saying you know okay i think this
but these are the things that would that
would cause me to have to rethink that
conclusion like you
you want to you want evidence that
anyone is
who you might listen to has both the
capacity to do that sort of analysis
and does it on the regular and also
and you know this is going to be tougher
to be revealed
will um will come back and correct the
record if they turn out to have been
wrong about something substantive not
you know every single little
little error but you know anything big
they'll come back they'll make an effort
um you know just just like newspapers do
or claim to right like they publish
corrections
like this this is what you must do if
you are
speaking with you know with the ability
to change how people behave and
therefore what outcomes will happen
you you absolutely need to be
responsible
to your own reputation because you are
responsible for other people's
choices and lives yep last thing i would
say
is biggest red flag might be that
there's a bigger red flag but as far
at the moment i think the biggest red
flag for me
is appeals to authority especially
somebody's appeal to their own authority
right in other words if somebody wants
to wave their degree
in front of your face as evidence that
they know what they're talking about
they probably don't
right that's one thing man if i've known
a lot of dem phds
a lot of dimples so damn so lazy so
incompetent
wrecked the meaning of the degree by
giving them out rather than paying
people to do the work of the university
so it's not to say that it's not
relevant that somebody has one
right or that somebody has it in their
signature file as
i think i do at this point but the point
is
does it stand in for an actual argument
right well somebody wield their phd
because they don't have an argument
right rather than it being just you know
who is making the argument yeah okay
they have a degree in such and such a
thing
right it tells you something about what
they're doing it allows you a first pass
like okay
then you know that maybe maybe they have
thought deeply about this thing yeah
on which they are down to speaking yeah
but somebody who pulls rank
just based on degrees or
institutions or whatever it is is almost
certainly covering for something
yeah um why there's
there's a lot more to say here but i'm
sure we will come back to the question
of expertise
and authority and what it actually means
to have a degree in a relevant field of
what a relevant field might be
um but i guess one more thing you know
as much as a phd in science
for you know for academics um is
often trotted out by people saying well
you know my phd is in
science therefore you sort of you know
trump's yours you know there is this
hierarchy
usually implicit but sometimes even
explicit within you know between
academic fields but unfortunately many
many many
so-called scientists now many people who
have phds in the sciences
aren't actually doing science and if
asked couldn't really describe to you
what science is they describe
the results of some scientific method
the you know the actual
products the outcome which is not the
science that's the results of the
science
and the fact that people who are
claiming to be scientists can't tell you
what science is
should be a big red flag yeah i agree
yeah
if they're uninterested in uh the
process and how it's
sensitive to certain kinds of
um of error then they're probably not
very good at it or as one
so-called scientist who i once taught
with announced to our class
well i used to think that hypotheses
were important but now i know better
yep yeah yeah my hypothesis is that he
was overpaid
indeed yes all right i think that brings
us to
the end of another q a episode
how did we get here how did we get here
we'll we will be doing another q a
episode tomorrow
only for our patreon members at my
patreon from
11 a.m pacific to 1pm enjoy my patreon
to get access to that
next saturday and sunday you're going to
be having your two hour
much more intimate conversations
coalition of the reasonable on saturday
and evolutionary discussion on sunday um
uh i'm changing up the mechanism by
which i'm
alerting people of these things because
of the hiccup a couple weeks ago
which we addressed this morning but um
i will make a standard patreon
announcement to the tier you're in
that's how you'll get it
rather than through the messages also as
a post
as a patreon post yep yep all right and
uh
yeah like that we will be back in the
new year it'll probably be next week but
there's some
vague chance that we will take a take a
one-week break but we'll certainly be
back in the new year we'll be back
in the new year if there is a new year
no
well all right i i i'm not going there
with you
no but just to be safe it seems like we
need a caveat like that
if we need to be safe like that we're
never getting off camera
all right well we will settle this and
we'll be back to you
very probably in the very probable new
year to tell you
how this argument played out oh that
should be fun
all right be well everyone